Customers are more likely to spread good word of mouth about your company and come back themselves...
...when they feel welcomed and valued,...
...and when they sense that you identify with their needs.
So, if your staff's phone skills and manners aren't actively encouraging repeat visits,...
...adopt these five simple rules.
Smile when you answer the phone.
Callers will hear the friendliness in your voice.
Speak slowly and clearly.
Don't make callers ask you to repeat yourself.
Refer to callers by name.
Most people like to hear the sound of their own name...
...and hearing you say it tells them they're important to you.
Be friendly but use courteous, respectful language.
You'll never know how callers may be judging you and by extension, your company.
And apply the golden rule to every caller.
Treat them the same way you'd like to be treated as a paying customer.
These rules may seem basic, but how many companies are living by them?
And remember, successful companies are often built on the basics.
Like a customer-centric attitude and the understanding that...
...every phone call is a chance to build customer share and create brand evangelists.